twenty-five-year-old
gives up his evenings delivering pizza
five nights a week in order to pay out
fifty five thousand dollars in debt I
think he's a millennial igni yeah you
know why did it cuz Dave Ramsey's a big
ol meanie because Dave Ramsey's a jerk
cuz dave ramsey doesn't understand a new
and then do with me you know why he did
it because he grew up I told him
indirectly over-the-air here which I
tell you over-the-air here all the time
adults devise a plan and follow it
children do what feels good now there
are children that are 58 years old and
there are grownups that are 25 years old
adults devise a plan and follow it they
live with a sense of intentionality they
do things on purpose instead of by
impulse they have the ability to delay
pleasure for a greater good and that's
called being a grown-up in saying things
that like that over the airwaves today
makes me a big old meanie Dave rims he's
nasty and I don't believe in dear MCS
advice then oh jeez oh by the way at the
commercial break I was out and I meant
to everyday millionaires during the
break both of them said they became
millionaires listening to what we teach
so my investment advice must be horrible
I mean the stuff i teach the mistakes I
make I mean thank God there's all of you
financial bloggers out there that have
800 people reading your blog they're
there to help people get through the
mistakes that Dave Ramsey makes thank
god you're there to save the world
unbelievable unbelievable so yeah I mean
that's how it works guys so the
interesting thing about what we teach
and the way we teach it with a little
sass admittedly a lot of sarcasm is that
some personality styles and political
persuasions can't stomach it and so
instead of saying something as simple as
I disagree then I have to personally be
vilified by them and that's part of the
routine that happens around here
regularly and it's more than a little
bit disgusting but not because I'm a
human being - it hurts my feelings like
ever hurt your feelings but we're going
to keep doing what we do which is show
that 25 year-old how to be a millionaire
and if he follows the stuff we're
teaching he'll be able to be a
millionaire you'll be able to be
outrageously generous and 100 percent of
time you can count on someone not
understanding that you have to make
peace with other people thinking you're
weird now I tell you to do this a lot of
different ways you know I say stuff like
if you're broke friends are making fun
of your financial plan you're probably
right on track you know and you can't
care what other people think if you're
going to get ahead none of those people
are going to pay for your bills and
retirement those people are going to
send your kid to college and they've all
got an opinion about your plan
isn't it interesting how people can't
mind their own business with their
negativity anymore and I had the unusual
benefit and it has lasted of going broke
when I was her age I was 26 when I
started going broke and by the time I
was 28 I was bankrupt and having started
from nothing I had four million dollars
were the real estate 25 years old 26
years only made $250,000 27 years old I
made six thousand dollars spent the year
losing everything we owned a two and a
half years there and the benefit of that
of course is that everything you thought
you knew is challenged and only the
truth when it when the fire is that hot
only truth doesn't burn
all the mythology burns up and one of
them thought one of the things that
burned up was my and I was really bad
y'all it's hard to believe listening to
me now because I'm so caustic and
sarcastic and everything else but I had
this unbelievable need for you I needed
you to think I was okay I needed you to
think I was successful and it was you at
a stoplight who I never met the car I
was driving you needed to think I was
successful going through the drive-thru
at the hamburger place you needed to
think I was successful the clothes I
wear walking through the mall you needed
to think I was successful I had a fake
Rolex that's how fake I was by the way
you can tell the fake ones because they
don't have a sweep hand they have a
quartz movement hand if you ever look
down and see a quartz movement a Rolex
you know it's a fake I was that fake and
going broke burned all of that melted it
to nothing to the point that mine need
to impress other people was completely
gone too much so actually I actually
should actually care a little bit what
you think but I just don't I just don't
I just do almost I don't take a poll on
anything I don't care what you think
there's almost the time you're wrong in
that bad I've gone the other way too far
but that's a benefit if you want to
build wealth because all these broke
people have stupid but opinions about
money and they will share their opinion